Alright. So it's worth asking, how do we find
this best line? So again there's an infinite number
of lines. How do we find one that fits
these points the best. And again we're defining best fit.
As the one that has the least squared error, where the error is
going to be some of the distances between these x points and the green line
that we, that we fit. I'm not even sure that this really is the
best fit in this case. I just kind of hand drew it. So, okay. So
is this something that we, that we would want to solve by hill climbing which
is to say, we kind of pick the. The slope and the intercept of
the line, and we just kind of try different values of this until it
gets better and better and then we can't get any better, and we stop.
Can we do this using calculus? Can we use random search, where we just
like, pick a random M, pick a random B, and see if we're happy
with it? Or is this the sort of thing where we probably would just
go and ask a physicist because it
involves, like, continuous quantities, and we're discrete people?